a lot of discussion on the David Pakman show
subreddit about the democratic primary, including
Hillary Clinton's recent comments about Bernie
Sanders. Remember, find the subreddit@davidpakman.com
slash R E. D D I T nearly 17,000 of our viewers
and listeners currently subscribed to the
subreddit. A few interesting posts, blue rice
posted will Hillary's attack on Bernie backfire
referring to Hillary Clinton saying recently
that Bernie Sanders that nobody likes Bernie
Sanders. Um, the post says, uh, I am a rooting
for Bernie or Warren to win the nomination.
Much like David Australia desperately needs
progressive leaders in light of the bushfires.
And I think a progressive president would
help shift the world's population to that
kind of thinking.
Having said that, I'm not optimistic about
Bernie or Warren's chances, but I want to
see what effect Hillary's attack on. Bernie
will have, if any. My question is, does Hillary
exemplify the mainstream politics that the
U S seemed to reject in 2016 when not considering
the popular vote more than Biden does if it
continues to be publicized, could Hillary's
attack paint Bernie as more of an antiestablishment
choice and invigorated a different section
of democratic voters? Or is Bernie already
seen as an anti establishment candidate amongst
us voters? I believe Bernie is already very
clearly seen as an antiestablishment candidate.
Sometimes to a fault in the sense that he
is couched as this outrageous radical who
wants to tear down all of the basic infrastructure
systems we have, which isn't true. He is just
a social Democrat in the sort of Northern
European sense. Uh, but I do believe that
Hillary Clinton's attack could backfire.
Uh, the thing is the backfire. There's, there's
two degrees. The first is could it backfire
and get Bernie the nomination? Question two
is what would happen if Bernie is the nominee
to the chances of removing Donald Trump? And
fortunately for all of us, we have new polling
about that which we will be talking about
a little bit later today. Another post on
the subreddit from a user who goes by the
name pedantically semantic says, is David
wrong about calling Bernie's label of democratic
socialism inaccurate? Adding that there does
seem to be an overlap in semantics, meaning
if the definition of social socialism is the
public ownership of the means of production
and the public is not specifically stated
as only the government and the public can
also mean a collective of the public like
cooperatives of cooperatives. And capitalism
is defined as the private ownership and private
can mean an individual can own.
So as you can see, this is a very semantically
intense question. I want to just answer it
from the top level, which is, as we've addressed
before, if democratic socialism now is being
understood to mean social democracy, isn't
it true that Bernie is a democratic socialist?
If what we mean by democratic socialist is,
is just social Democrat, I don't even think
we need to have that conversation. Uh, the,
the conversation that I've had, uh, is that
when socialism is discussed in many circles,
the actual definition is still used. And so
for clarity, I believe it makes more sense
for Bernie to say that he is running a candidacy
on social democracy, not democratic socialism.
I can see that over time in society if we
start using a different word for something
or if we change the definition of a word,
these are things we can determine.
And that may be the case. I don't believe
we've gotten to that point. And I think that
there is only more confusion, not less when
Bernie Sanders is called a democratic socialist.
Even though the policies or the of social
democracy, people can disagree about this.
That's my view as of right now. Join the discussion@davidpakman.com
slash Reddit